with the farm growing in numbers and The
Gargoyle King at large it's only a
matter of time before a cent a night
comes for Riverdale our heroes are
fighting their biggest threat yet and
they don't even know who or what they're
up against could the Black Hood and The
Gargoyle King be one in the same is
aren't you going to join the farm after
his dad suddenly passes away watch until
the end is to find out the corner let's
start things off by putting a very
low-key character in the spotlight as
many of you know that he has become
quite chummy with the local coroner dr.
Cornel Junior he's helped her solve
crimes by revealing classified
information about River Dells the latest
victims are we the only ones who think
that this character is a little
suspicious we mean he seriously gives us
the creeps dr. Cornel junior took over
his father's business after his passing
so it's safe to say that the curdles
have been in Riverdale for generations
we wouldn't be surprised if dr. Cornel
senior was the gargoyle King back in his
day and it's very possible that he
trained his son to take over the family
legacy in season 3 episode 18 dr. Cornel
junior tells Betty that baby teeth was
murdered by something not human which
struck us as strange could the corner be
trying to trick Betty into thinking that
the gargoyle King isn't human when he in
fact is Betty is so used to going to dr.
Cornel jr. for answers that she's
forgotten that he's a story of his own
by now we all know that families who are
native to Riverdale have a long and dark
past so it was it really too far-fetched
to point a finger at the terrifying
helpful corner Edgar the Warlock alright
enough about dr. Cornel jr. let's focus
on the man of the hour
Edgar ever never
well I was wondering when we'd finally
meet this charming cult leader has
stolen the hearts of many women and men
so much so that they left their old
lives behind to stand by aside fans were
surprised that Evelyn was in fact
Edgar's wife but we saw this coming from
a mile away who we mean she totally
loves him Edgar has a way of getting
inside people's heads heck he even had
Betty believing that she was the evil
one so how and why does Edgar have this
ability while we could blame his
persuasive powers on his silver tongue
we're not sure that's all it is because
well it looks like his cult members are
in some sort of trance could it be
possible that Edgar is a warlock now
before you say magic doesn't exist let's
look at the facts first of all the
original Archie comics were swirling
with magical properties so it's safe to
say that the show would follow in the
footsteps of the comic on top of that we
all know that Riverdale's neighboring
town Greendale is oozing with witches
and warlocks so it's totally possible
that a warlock has left town to claim
human lives in the name of the Dark Lord
do you guys watch Chilean adventures of
Sabrina if so let us know what you think
about this crossover theory in the
comment section the magical town of
Riverdale while we're on the topic of
magic we thought it would be a good idea
to talk about Edgar's endgame it's clear
to us that Polly's twins are of great
value to Edgar and the farm okay well
maybe just the girl twin but more on
that later in season 3 episode 1
Betty suffered a seizure after
witnessing her mother dropping her
grandchildren into a bonfire but to
Betty's great surprise the twins floated
up and survived if this wasn't a magical
ritual we don't know what is at the end
of season 3 episode 18
Fetty nearly joins the farm when editor
points out that her entire family is
there the cult members whisper join us
as they slowly advance causing Betty to
fall into a strange trance however her
reverie is broken off when she remembers
Polly and her mother throwing the twins
into the fire this is enough to snap her
back into reality which sends the farm
on a wild goose chase to catch the last
Cooper
so here's our theory Edgar sacrifices
young children to keep his youthful
appearance we wouldn't be surprised if
Edgar was as old as dust his charming
appearance could all be a facade to
prolong his lifespan and expand his
riches do you guys think Edgar is
showing his true face
we highly doubt it you can look but you
can't touch if there's one thing we just
can't shake it's the fact that everyone
in the farm has seen their deceased
loved ones Alice sees Charles
Cheryl sees Jason and Evelyn probably
sees her real father still it's not like
these dead people are walking around
town grabbing milkshakes at pops
chocolate shop still the cult members
seem super convinced that they are
seeing their loved ones in the flesh we
know that the sisters of quiet Mercy
used to give their patients
Hisle rocks to convince them that the
gargoyle king was real but we don't
think that the same thing is happening
at the farm in fact Evelyn made it
painfully obvious that the farm members
don't put anything foreign into their
bodies in fear the reaper Tony goes
undercover to help Betty find out what's
really happening at the farm but before
that she and Cheryl chat about Jason and
whether or not Cheryl has actually
hugged him Cheryl goes on to say that
she has but it's obvious that she's
lying so now we know that Cheryl and
Alice are only allowed to see their
loved ones and not touch them could
Edgar be using his magical powers to
call these lost souls from the grave
although we have some pretty convincing
twin theories at large it's quite
possible that Edgar is tricking everyone
around him the girls win Polly Cooper
has lived on the farm for quite a while
now she convinced her mother to join her
side so we have her to thank for Edgar
and Alice's future wedding think I have
someone who can help you mom a friend of
mine in the farm from the looks of
things
Edgar is married to every single person
on the farm the men included this could
be why Evelyn has been recruiting males
who belong to the LGBTQ community this
way they won't have any issues with
Marion Edgar Betty went to great lengths
to rescue the twins from the farm
however she only managed to get her
hands on Dagwood the boy twin Betty
convinced Penelope blossom to rescue the
twins
however Penelope was content with only
taking the boy no grandmother would ever
leave one of their grandchildren behind
so we have to admit this was pretty
suspicious it's almost as if Penelope
has done this before so here's our
theory Penelope gave up Jason's real
twin girl to the sisters of quiet mercy
and took Cheryl in instead this little
switcheroo was expected of her as a sort
of retribution but the question remains
what on earth is the farm planning to do
with the girl twin is little juniper
going to be sacrificed during a cinch a
night we sure hope not breakups and
makeups
all right enough about us in tonight and
twin trading let's set our sights on
Archie and Veronica in season 3 episode
18 Josie finally got her golden ticket
the young star in the making will soon
be leaving Riverdale so it was only
fitting that she break things off with
our team but as she so plainly put it
they just weren't endgame so now that
Josie's out of the picture it's only a
matter of time before Archie and
Veronica get back together right but
which couple will have to break up to
bring barchi back to life as many of you
know there's a TV series rule that goes
something like this
two couples kiss be happy and thriving
at the same time so if Varkey doesn't
rise from the ashes it's only a matter
of time before Betty and Jughead start
having a relationship troubles we don't
like this rule any more than you do
still Betty and Jughead have been going
strong for so long that their
relationship is bound to hit a slope at
some point we just hope that Varkey and
bug head will be able to double dates
for a little while before troubles arise
in paradise
Archie joins the farm Archie's life has
been pretty chaotic
ever since Veronica Lodge moved into
town my mom and I just moved here from
where New York
he's gained Hyrum Lodge as an enemy
while becoming a person of great
interest to the gargoyle King the red
paladin is strong beyond belief which is
why so many Griffins and gargoyles
players have tried to conquer him Archie
has gone to jail been on the run and
faced a murder charge after his opponent
passed away in the ring all in all
things have not been going Archie's way
and sadly enough things are about to get
even worse episode 18 fear the reaper is
said to be the last episode that
features Fred Andrews the beloved late
actor has been gracing us with his
presence on the screen but that's about
to come to an end
Archie is going to suffer his biggest
loss yet which will make him vulnerable
if the farm can in fact connects people
with the dead archie might find himself
enthralled by it
and since edgar loves himself a redhead
he won't be able to refuse
Archie's got a strong head on his
shoulders which is why he wouldn't
typically fall for a cult leader
shenanigans but since he'll be coming
from a place of pure desperation and
sorrow anything is possible
Archie would definitely see Fred in
Edgar's secret room but would he believe
it to be his real father or a
manifestation of his deepest wishes only
time will tell
gargoyle King the black hood many of us
were shocked when it was revealed that
how Cooper was the black hood so we
can't help but feel as though how wasn't
working alone after all he's just not
that smart
the black hood terrorized Riverdale for
two seasons before being replaced by the
gargoyle King but what if these two
evils were one in the same
much like the black hood the gargoyle
King has many faces the disguised figure
often appears in the woods and seems to
be far from human
however he's been unmasked before tall
boy posed as the gargoyle King to
frighten his enemies however the true
gargoyle King is still at large
duck had came face to face with him
after the King murdered his loyal player
kurz could it be possible that how
Cooper is also the gargoyle King if this
is true he would definitely need some
help but who in Riverdale has got housed
back rip Hal you guessed it none other
than Penelope blossom the
wild card has got everyone wrapped
around her finger she and Hal have a
very close relationship and she often
visits him in jail on top of that she's
got a green thumb and the ability to
grow hazardous substances it's possible
that Penelope is behind the distribution
of faulty fizzle rocks in Riverdale it's
also possible that she used Kurtz to
distract Jughead and FP Jones while
rescuing howl from JAL while being moved
to a different prison how Cooper was
allegedly killed
however we highly doubt that this is
true by getting the Joneses to commit a
series of crimes throughout Riverdale
the police force wasn't as strong as it
should have been which could have
allowed Penelope's ghouls to stage house
death Penelope always has a convincing
sneer in her face and by poisoning her
customers and creating a new threat she
was able to rescue her lover how Cooper
the truth about Penelope blossom
Penelope blossom was raised to be a
heartless and calculating person and she
tends to have a hidden agenda I hope you
enjoyed yourself we know that she's a
serial killer who poisons men so she's
definitely a contender
Penelope was born and raised at the
sisters of quiet mercy where she might
have been groomed to become the next
gargoyle King Penelope is definitely up
to something and she's not working alone
the blossoms have been terrorizing
Riverdale for generations and how Cooper
is also a blossom in disguise
if vanellope and how are truly working
together this makes us wonder if the
farm is connected to the gargoyle King
or if Edgar has an agenda of his own
Penelope is looking more and more
suspicious as time goes on
what are Hal and Penelope playing at do
you guys think that Penelope is the
gargoyle King and if so what does the
farm have to do with Griffin's and
gargoyles sound off in the comments
below and that's a wrap
we hope you liked our Riverdale Theory
video like always give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to the things thanks for watching we'll
see you soon
[Music]